foreign
I ate his liver with some fava beans and
a nice Chianti
you fly back to school now little
starting
hey there it's Mark welcome back to RT
Essentials I'm getting Goosebumps just
thinking about the movies we'll be
discussing today and look I'm usually
all about horror whether it's
supernatural your slashers your found
footage your psychological you name it I
can handle it provided the lights are on
it's just that the Selections in this
list fall more into the category of
frightening because they were inspired
by true events yes these things actually
kind of really happened look a film
inspired by true events we'll take some
serious Liberties as opposed to a film
based on true events which more closely
follows the reality path but still again
you turn the lights off doesn't make it
any less scary as we discuss these films
we'll also be detailing the real events
that influence them just to raise the
Fright factor and that was the hair in
my arm standing up it's a good spine
chilling fun episode of RT Essentials
here comes the best horror movies
inspired by true events The Exorcist if
that's true
and you must know my mother's maiden
name
what is it
what is it
The Exorcist was directed by William
friedkin and tells the story of a young
girl named Reagan who starts exhibiting
Strange Behaviors like speaking in
tongues and levitating you know kid
stuff her worried mother seeks medical
help and hits a dead end leaving her no
other option but to turn to a local
priest father Damian Karis father Karis
makes a request to perform an exorcism
on Reagan who he believes has been
seized by the devil and with the help of
an older experienced Catholic priest
father Marin the two performed the
daunting demon ridding ritual everything
about this movie is terrifying the
performances the off-putting music the
special effects Reagan doing a spider
crawl down the staircase while spewing
blood but the real life story that
influenced the Exorcist is even more
terrifying Reagan's character was
inspired by a young boy known as Ronald
I see what you did there who went
through dozens of exorcisms in the late
1940s after a series of disturbing
events Ronald's bed would suddenly Shake
he'd hear strange scratch sounds coming
from the walls and basement and foul
smells would fill his room much like the
movie Ronald's family turned to two
Catholic priests who were granted
permission to perform the exorcism and
much like the movie inexplicable events
transpired during the ride such as
objects mysteriously flying across the
room strange scratches appearing on
Ronald's body the priest detailed these
real-life events as they took place and
their notes served as the basis for
author William Peter blatty's
best-selling novel of the same name
bloody would eventually adapt his own
novel into the oscar-winning screenplay
for The Exorcist
in the name of the father
and of the Sun
that the Holy Spirit
by this sign of the Holy Cross of our
Lord Jesus Christ who lives and reigns
with the father and the Holy Spirit
this film is widely considered to be the
scariest movie ever by movie lovers
pundits experts and the guy talking
right now and when we ingest for
inflation it's still the highest
grossing R-rated movie of all time I
mean you talk about casting a shadow
that's very creepy very long very dark
and tends to spin its head that's what
the Exorcist has done the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre
foreign
writer director Toby Hooper marketed The
Texas Chainsaw Massacre as being based
on true events a tactic that helped
attract a wider audience and further
added to the hysteria surrounding the
film's release the movie follows Sally
and her paraplegic brother Franklin as
they set out to investigate the
vandalization of their grandfather's
grave Sally Franklin and some friends
stopped at their Family's old farmhouse
uh oh I know where this is going and
soon discovered that a group of crazed
murderous outcasts are living next door
one by one Sally and Company are
attacked by the chainsaw wielding
Leatherface who Sports a mask made it's
not actually leather it's human skin
naturally this film left a lot of people
skeptical of their neighbors and
certainly helped to establish the creepy
Farmhouse horror trope
foreign
marketing POI left many viewers
convinced that the film's contents were
rooted in reality but the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre was only inspired by true
events like the murders committed by
Elmer Wayne Henley and Dean Coral in
Texas and the accounts of one serial
killer in particular named Ed Gein also
known as The Butcher of Plainfield gains
crimes were widely publicized in the
1950s after authorities discovered that
he'd been exhuming corpses and using
their bones and skin to create masks and
other horrifying objects in addition to
Leatherface gain inspired many other
characters in film and television such
as Norman Bates from psycho and Buffalo
Bill from Silence of the Lambs uh more
on him later but the idea to have
Leatherface's weapon of choice be a
chainsaw was not inspired by gain and
actually came to Hooper while he was
Christmas shopping in a crowded hardware
store it tis the season A Nightmare on
Elm Street
[Music]
foreign
Street was the first installment in the
hugely successful franchise that now
consists of nine films and at the core
of this franchise is one of the most
iconic horror characters ever created
the Fedora wearing metal clawed joke
cracking Freddy Krueger Krueger
consistently ranks as one of the
greatest villains in cinematic history
but most people aren't familiar with Wes
Craven's inspiration for the character
and film in the late 1990s Craven spoke
of reading a newspaper article about a
young immigrant who had fled to the
United States during the Cambodian Civil
War and was complaining to his parents
about having nightmares he was so scared
of these nightmares that he did
everything he could to avoid falling
asleep including keeping a coffee pot in
his room one night while watching TV
downstairs he passed out so his parents
carried him up to his room and felt
relieved that he was finally getting
some rest an hour later they heard
screams and rushed to the boy's bedroom
only to find him dead this form of
psychological Terror was classified as
sudden unexplained nocturnal death
syndrome and many of the young men that
fled southeast Asia during that period
experienced some form of this
[Music]
so Craven took this story and combined
it with his own experience of being
bullied in school by a boy named
you guessed it Fred Krueger and this
classic slasher film about a midnight
Mangler who preys on teenagers in their
dreams was born if nothing else what a
great PSA for anti-bullying The
Amityville Horror
next is the master bedroom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
The Amityville Horror was directed by
Stuart Rosenberg and is based on the
1977 Jay Anson book of the same name it
follows the Lutz family who are
terrorized by Supernatural forces after
moving into a new house in New York
state which also happens to be the site
of a recent Mass killing but hey
location location it's a good deal you
gotta close it when the house is
suddenly swarmed with flies and pipes
start oozing slime and blood the let's
call on a local priest to exercise the
evil spirits inhabiting the home Anson's
book was based on the experiences of the
real Lutz family who claimed that a
malevolent force in their newly
purchased home would cause them to
suddenly levitate and objects would fly
across the room they'd even sometimes
see glowing red eyes the Lutz family was
so freaked out that they fled the home
in the middle of the night only weeks
after moving in
come on
Kathy
because the book and film were based on
the account of the real family and the
house was indeed the real location of a
violent murder many believe the story to
be true but since its release several
people have come forward to rebut the
original claims of the Lutz family
including the priest who bless the home
and the later owners of the house who
could not substantiate the damage claims
they were described in the book what
true or not the Amityville Horror became
one of the highest grossing independent
films ever and spawned a commercially
successful franchise and it still lives
rent free in my head
The Conjuring
[Music]
set in the early 1970s The Conjuring
follows paranormal investigators
Lorraine and Ed Warren who are summoned
to the home of Carolyn and Roger Perrin
after Supernatural presence has made
itself
known the parents and their five
daughters have recently moved into this
secluded Farmhouse and as I'm sure
you've deduced things escalate in a
horrifying fashion I'm getting serious
Amityville Vibes here in fact Lorraine
and Ed were a real couple who also
consulted on that case The Conjuring was
inspired by the real parent family who
after moving into their dream home in
Harrisville Rhode Island started
noticing Spirits some That Grew
increasingly ornery Carolyn Perrin
researched the history of the home and
discovered that it had been in the same
family for many generations and several
family members that had lived there had
died under horrifying circumstances like
drowning in the creek behind the home
one member was murdered and a few hanged
themselves in the Attic chefs
the Saints and all the angels I command
you to reveal yourself
one spirit that was depicted in the film
Bathsheba was considered the most evil
of them all according to the real Andrea
Perrin the eldest of the five parent
daughters Bathsheba perceived herself to
be the Mistress of the house and she
resented the competition that her mother
carowind posed for that position further
investigations into the home history
revealed that a real person named
Bathsheba did in fact live there in the
mid-1800s and she was believed to be a
drumroll please Satanist though Andrea
parent has admitted that the film took
some Liberties Lorraine Warren insists
that the hauntings were real and that
all the events depicted actually
happened Open Water
High School
I thought he said they never come that
close they also said the boat would be
here
next up we're taking a little break from
the ghost infested homes to discuss Open
Water the tale of Daniel and Susan an
American couple who embark on a tropical
vacay ready for some serious scuba
action while on a group dive they get
left behind thanks to an incorrect head
count you had one job count the heads
it's all you had to do when Daniel and
Susan resurfaced they realized their
boat has departed and now they must
survive the open Waters with Hungry
Sharks lurking just beneath them the
story was Loosely based on a real
married couple Thomas and Eileen
lottergen who were unintentionally
abandoned while diving off the coast of
Australia in 1998 their absence went
unnoticed for two days and was only
realized when their belongings were
discovered on the dive boat a massive
air and sea search ensued over the next
few days but neither Eileen or Thomas
were ever found and are presumed dead
I don't see it are you okay
obviously there's no way of knowing
exactly what happened to Thomas or
Eileen in their final moments so the
film was forced to take some serious
Liberties like making shark attacks the
driving mechanism of fear but most
theories suggest that the couple had
succumb to dehydration and inevitably
drown as opposed to being eaten by very
famous cinematic animals open water was
a box office success and received mostly
positive reviews with many hailing it as
a welcome addition to the somewhat over
saturated shark movie market and if
you're wondering how director Chris
kentus made the sharks in the film look
so realistic is because they're real
sharks yeah take that Bruce Poltergeist
and just like that we're back to
possessed homes Poltergeist was directed
by Toby Hooper remember the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre guy the one who really
hates Christmas shopping yeah so this
story was created by Steven Spielberg
who also co-wrote the script and it
focuses on the strange happenings that
unfold at the free links family home
when ghosts are communicating through
the TV set and the friendly and playful
Spirits within the house get angry and
abduct the youngest daughter Carol the
freelings must turn to a parasiteologist
at eventually an exorcist for help
Spielberg originally intended for this
film to be a sequel to Close Encounters
of the Third Kind but Hooper insisted
they lean into the horror genre and they
made it a ghost movie but the story
didn't just appear in amount of mashed
potatoes it was based on the real tale
of James and Lucille Herman from Long
Island New York who reported strange
activities such as bottle cast
mysteriously popping off and bookshelves
tipping over on their own when
authorities ruled out possible
electrical disturbances the Hermits were
left with no other option but to bring a
priest coincidentally the Herman home
was only seven miles from The Amityville
Horror house you cannot make this stuff
up and they literally didn't
[Music]
[Music]
many consider Poltergeist to be a cursed
movie due to the real life tragedy
surrounding several the cast members
such as actress Heather O'Rourke who
played Carol and died from Health
complications at the age of 12 and
Dominic Dunn Who played Dana and was
murdered by her ex-boyfriend at the age
of 22. cursed or not there's no denying
that Poltergeist is one of the scariest
films ever made and I will never again
have a clown in my bedroom
scream
[Music]
[Music]
was inspired by American serial killer
Danny Rowling aka the Gainesville Ripper
rolling murdered five college students
in Gainesville Florida over a four-day
period in August of 1990 and later
confessed to committing a triple
homicide in his home City of Freeport
Louisiana the Gainesville Ripper was
featured on an episode of Turning Point
which aspiring screenwriter actor Kevin
Williamson happened to catch while he
was house sitting in Los Angeles
Williamson started to panic the
combination of the Erie TV special being
alone in a strange home and then
realizing that he had left a window open
was too much for him to handle did he
put Jiffy Pop on that night well he
grabbed a kitchen knife just to be safe
and began checking the house and then
instead of running out the front door he
called a friend so the friend started
mocking Williamson by bringing up horror
movies and the two soon began discussing
their favorite films in that genre so
just like that the idea for scream was
conceived as soon as Williamson hung up
the phone he penned an 18-page treatment
that served as the iconic opening
sequence of the film
yes okay number two you can never drink
or do drugs
[Applause]
and number three never ever ever under
any circumstances say I'll be right back
because you won't be back I'm getting
another beer you want one yeah sure I'll
be right back
when we adjust for inflation scream is
the highest grossing slash for film of
all time and it wouldn't exist if
Williamson hadn't caught that one TV
special on that one fateful night made a
faithful phone call and I'm gonna go
ahead and say cooked a fateful batch of
Jiffy Pop Wolf Creek
[Music]
around the bush
the same cool stuff up
[Music]
this is a knife
[Music]
wolfbrick was directed and written by
Greg McLean and follows three Backpacker
friends whose rickety car breaks down
when you just don't want a car to break
down you see they're stopped at Wolf
Creek National Park in Western Australia
a mysterious Bush man named Mick Taylor
finds the group of friends and offers to
tow them to his camp and repair their
car wow what a generous guy I don't know
about you but mix seems like someone you
can count on oh wait he takes everyone
captive and starts torturing and killing
them like clockwork yep yep that was my
other guess
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's not a moment
this
[Music]
McLean was inspired by serial killer
Ivan milot known as The Backpacker
murderer who infamously captured robbed
and murdered Two Men and five women in
New South Wales between 1989 and 1992.
McLean had originally drafted a
straightforward slasher film but ended
up rewriting it after seeing media on
moat's killing he wanted to create a
villain that Blended the archetypal
Australian outbacker with more sadistic
National figures according to Mclean the
film was meant to portray what it would
be like to be stuck in an incredibly
isolated place with the most evil
character you can possibly imagine who
is also distinctly Australian well
McQueen if that was your intention I'd
say good on you mate The Silence of the
Lambs you still wake up sometimes don't
you
wake up in the dark
and hear the screaming of the Lamb
do you think if you save poor Catherine
you could make them stop don't you you
think if Catherine lives
you won't wake up in the dark ever again
to that awful screaming of the Lambs
last but certainly not the least is the
Silence of the Lambs directed by
Jonathan Demi and written by Ted towie
adapted from the 1988 novel the same
name the film stars Jody Foster as
Clarice Starling a top student at the
FBI's Training Academy Starling is
tasked with interviewing Dr Hannibal
Lecter a brilliant psychiatrist who also
happens to be a violent psychopath and
is serving life behind bars for various
acts of murder and you guessed it
cannibalism Starling and Lecter form a
curious Bond and Lecter becomes
instrumental in hunting down another
murderous Menace Buffalo Bill
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so as I mentioned earlier when
discussing Leatherface Ed gains creepy
obsession with human skin had an
influence on the characters in this
movie but Buffalo Bill actually shares
similarities with a combination of
serial killers that in addition to gain
included Ted Bundy Jerry brudos and Gary
heidman each of these killers had
specific methods for luring torturing
and murdering their victims additionally
the relationship between Starling and
Lecter was influenced by the real-life
interviews conducted between FBI agents
and Ted Bundy and attempts to help them
capture the grain River Killer the FBI
fully cooperated in the production of
this film and saw it as a useful tool
for recruiting more female agents
Silence of the lamps is the only horror
film to ever win the Oscar for best
picture and is one of only three films
to ever win all five Major Academy
Awards if you haven't seen this one I'd
highly recommend trading out the popcorn
for some fava beans and an iced tea
answer and that wraps up our list of the
best horror movies inspired by true
events of course countless films have
taken inspiration from The Real World
but there just isn't enough time to
discuss them all so if we missed one
don't fret we got lots of episodes of RT
Essentials coming your way so we will
get there eventually thanks for tuning
in I'm Mark Ellis and I'll be right back
oh no I just did it to myself
[Applause]
[Music]